Security Forces confront protesters in
the southern region of punu the
government says nearly 9 000
demonstrators using homemade weapons and
explosives tried to overrun the airport
in the city of huliaka security forces
responded with live ammunition it's the
deadliest day in more than one month of
violence across Peru
I was holding my camera when a police
officer asked me to kneel while pointing
a gun at me then I heard a shot and felt
my foot blocked then I felt a cramp I
took four steps I fell on the floor
because I couldn't walk
officials say ambulances were prevented
from moving freely a doctor was killed
while assisting the wounded and a 17
year old girl was shot and killed in the
crossfire hospitals are overflowing with
some of the Wounded in critical
condition
I want to call on the central government
how can we have so many dead people tens
of thousands of people have marched to
demand the resignation of President
dinaboluarte markets have been looted
roads blocked in 25 provinces are on
strike
some of the victims were bystanders hit
by stray bullets
he was out walking his friend lives
nearby and they went for a walk
far as We Know
about the government blames former
president Pedro Castillo for the
month-long unrest
who announced the coup d'etat from the
same Government Palace who is
coordinating these demonstrations to
seek impunity and to achieve what they
did not know how to achieve or were not
allowed to achieve the answer is in jail
Castillo was ousted in December after he
tried to shut down Congress and arrest
the prosecutor investigating him for
alleged corruption
with the violin spiraling some members
of parliament say they are unlikely to
give the cabinet a vote of confidence on
Tuesday further deepening the crisis
the government has promised to restore
peace but many peruvians are unsatisfied
and they say they will take their
demonstrations to the capital to demand
that President stepped down and new
elections be held immediately Lima